[Music]
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I focused on
dramatically improving a few things
surprise surprise most notably the
quality of my sleep which seems to
affect just about everything this led me
to revisit you name it my daily routine
morning routine exercise diet all the
way to what I slept on and I ended up
getting all new beds here in Austin
Texas including mattresses from helix
sleep helix has built a sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete and they
use the answers to match your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper or you like
plush you like firm with helix there's
no more guessing or confusion just go to
helix sleep calm forward-slash Tim take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life that is
their promise for couples helix can even
split the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they have
a 10 year warranty and you can test
drive your mattress for a 100 nights
risk-free right now helix is offering up
to one hundred and twenty-five dollars
off of all mattress orders so check it
out
get up to 125 off at helix sleep comm
forward slash Tim that's helix sleep
dot-com forward slash Tim for one
hundred and twenty five dollars off your
mattress order tickle ik helix sleep
comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by ship
station
if you've ever sold anything online or
if you sell anything online then you
know what a pain in the ass the shipping
process is it's time-consuming it's
expensive
you're always copying and pasting orders
from different sites trying to figure
out the best carrier so on and so forth
it's such a hassle and in a previous
life I shipped tens of thousands of
units overseas domestically overnight
ground every possible carrier it drove
me bonkers ship station was created to
make your life easier I wish I had had
it when I was in the biz so to speak it
has the most five-star reviews of any
shipping software four point nine out of
five for Magento users four point eight
out of five for Shopify users four point
five out of five for big commerce users
it goes on and on whether you're selling
on eBay Amazon Shopify or more than 100
other popular selling channels
shipstation lets you access all your
orders from one simple dashboard
shipstation works with all of the major
shipping carriers locally and globally
including FedEx UPS and the major local
couriers like USPS ship station will
recommend the best carrier for your
needs so that you know that you're
always getting the best deal they even
offer discounts on shipping costs that
are available to say you as a one-person
shop that would normally be thought of
as reserved for large fortune 500
companies so there are a lot of benefits
no other shipping platform makes
shipping faster easier and more
affordable and right now Tim Ferriss
show listeners get to try ship station
free for 60 days when you use promo code
Tim it's risk free you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info just visit ship station
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Tim T I am
that ship station comm enter promo code
Tim check it out ship station comm promo
code Tim
well hello boys and girls dingos and
wombats ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show and I am
mentioning more animals than usual for a
reason my job every episode as some of
you may know is to deconstruct
world-class performers and or people who
are extremely well known in their
respective fields to deconstruct how
they do what they do the thinking
behaviors influences and so on that make
them different and my guest
this episode is Mike Phillips and
there's really something for everyone in
this episode whether you want to get a
better understanding of the natural
world in ecology or you just want to
avoid being mauled by bears if you're in
bear country there's something for you
Mike Phillips Mike has served as the
executive director of the Turner
endangered species fund and the adviser
to the Turner biodiversity division
since he co-founded both with Ted Turner
in June of 1997 before that Mike worked
for the US Department of Interior
leading historic efforts to restore red
wolves to the southeastern US and gray
wolves to the Yellowstone National Park
if you've seen the video online how
wolves change rivers on YouTube with 40
million plus views that is a short story
a reflection of those efforts he also
conducted important research on the
impacts of oil and gas development on
Bruce Lee bears in the Arctic predation
costs for gray wolves in Alaska and
dingo ecology in Australia in 2006 Mike
was elected to the Montana House of
Representatives he served there until
elected to the Montana Senate in 2012
his service in the Senate will extend
through 2020 and Mike received his
master's in science and wildlife ecology
from the University of Alaska and his
Bachelors of Science in ecology from the
University of Illinois so this episode
and past conversations with Mike have
led me to find the opportunity that I'm
currently most excited about
aside from psychedelic research at
places like Hopkins and Imperial College
and elsewhere this has become what I'm
most excited about
and we'll get to what that is in the
episode but I had the same feeling with
this and it's not a common feeling but
the same tingle in the belly feeling
that I had when I was first looking at
getting involved with some of the
startups that I've been involved with in
early stages duolingo Facebook Twitter
Shopify so when you say gage meat I
should say a small team like the Shopify
team at the time which was something
like 10 or 12 people there's sometimes a
tingle in the belly that reflects the
feeling the realization that this could
be really really big this could really
be huge and it makes sense and so we
will talk about in this episode
something that triggered that same
response at me where I'm going to be
applying a lot of focus and without
further ado please enjoy a at times very
hilarious at times very profound and
certainly wide-ranging conversation with
Mike Phillips Mike welcome to the show
Tim it's my pleasure to be here I
couldn't remember that I'd done all
those things so thank you for reminding
me of where I have been in the past well
I may do more of that and that'd be
helpful as I get older I get forgetful
and one of those those old memories that
I thought we might stoke is related to
grizzly bears and you and I connected
through another scientist who
recommended we speak which came about
because long ago I saw a video and we'll
probably talk about this but how wolves
change rivers which led me to reach out
to my friends sonjin who's been on this
podcast before Conservation
International and he led me to Kevin who
led me to you and that's the background
for people listening grizzly bears I'm
looking at one of these bullets and it
says that their muzzles are
blood-stained but their teeth are green
could you explain that why why that is
that's a great start Tim thank you well
many years ago I was studying grizzly
bear behavior and habitat
use in the Arctic National Wildlife
Refuge in anticipation of oil and gas
development but for a period of time I
was part of a capture crew we would we
would dart grizzly bears from
helicopters that the drug would take
effect the bear would lay down and go to
sleep and and my job on the capture crew
was to was to extract a premolar if you
take a tooth from a grizzly bear or many
other animals for that matter you can
section the tooth very finely and just
like with a tree you can come up with a
good estimate of age by Counting annual
I yearly growth rings so my job was to
be the local dentist and pull a tooth
from this grizzly bear now every bear
that I handled Tim the muscles were
bloody dried blood or wet blood and the
muscles were bloody because at that time
of the year grizzly bears were making
extensive use of caribou canvas the
porcupine caribou herd 140,000 animals
strong they calves and mass on the
coastal plain of northern Alaska
well grizzly bears know this and
interested in a pulse of animal protein
in early summer so they go out to the
coastal plain and they they hunt these
caribou calves and you know quite
successfully for at least a few days so
every one of these bears had a bloody
muzzle and you think well this is a what
a fantastic carnivore bloody muzzles but
every bear that I handled that I pulled
the tooth from when I would pull them
the the lips of the bear back to get at
the teeth their teeth were all green now
that teeth weren't bloody the teeth were
stained a deep green and the message to
that story or the lesson from that story
is looks can be deceiving grizzly bears
all over the world mostly subsist on
vegetation they eat so much vegetation
that their teeth are stained green at
least animals I handled the Arctic in
contrast that flash of animal protein in
the form of a few caribou calves across
a few days gives you this dramatic
portrayal of predation with blood on the
muzzle but she was for the ecology of
the Great Bear they're mostly living on
plants sometimes things aren't as they
seem
yeah I I may share some
some grizzly bear stories later but I've
I've spent some time in the Brooks Range
in Alaska and always wondered about that
because I've been to the births range
during caribou migrations and have seen
grizzly bears which at least the locals
sometimes refer to as barren ground
Grizzlies because there's there's almost
no tree cover at least where I was and
it seemed very very very difficult for
them to to catch caribou and in which
case what's left it's green yeah it is
tough it is barren ground country there
are no trees sure well north the tree
line that some of the shrubs are big
enough they begin to resemble trees this
work was done in the Brooks Range so you
and I spent time in the same country it
is a tough place to make it living that
the Bears don't have access to a long
growing season they've got to be smart
about what they do and the smart bear
understands that while I might kill a
few caribou calves over the course of a
couple of days and when you understand
caribou caribou give birth to what would
be called followers the caribou calf
within short order
a day or two is able to follow the herd
without any problem in contrast to other
ungulates hoofed mammals like
white-tailed deer white-tailed deer give
birth to hiders it takes a white-tailed
deer fawn longer to mature so their
strategy is to be very good at hiding
caribou calves without a lot of country
to hide in oh boy they give birth to
followers and those calves get up and go
in short order are very capable at
following the herd so capable well they
can outrun a grizzly bear at 2 or 3 or 4
days of age and so the Bears have this
very narrow window of opportunity as
that calf is beginning to get his hooves
underneath him so to speak you you could
have taken so many different career
paths you could have studied so many
different things how did you end up
focusing so much on predators well I'm
intrigued by rareness as an ecologist
I'm intrigued by rareness and by
definition
just the way every natural system is
structured the way energy flows through
a system carnivores are always
relatively uncommon certainly far more
uncommon than the prey that they consume
and of course the prey are more uncommon
than the plants that they consume so
I've been intrigued by predation for a
long time I'm intrigued by carnivores
because of rareness and early in my
career Tim even before I did grizzly
bear work I was deeply situated in the
world of wolf conservation and and while
gray wolves are fantastic and I'm
fascinated by gray wolves I'm fascinated
by lots of native life-forms gray wolves
gave me the chance to focus on
restoration because when I started grey
wolf work back in 1980 and I've been
working on wolf recovery nearly daily
now since 1980 when I began gray wolves
were very very very uncommon and and I
was seduced I was seduced him by this
notion of restoration taking something
that was a Miss and putting it back
together again that that's that's what
kept me fixated if you will on on
carnivore sin' and restoration and why
not become an attorney or a math teacher
or a an Instagram model why did you
choose why did you choose nature why did
you choose ecology was there any
formative experience or conversation
fork in the road that led you into that
world to begin with yeah well dude I
would be a lousy model so that's not on
the buddy now teaching is valuable and
important serving as an attorney we're a
country guided by laws that's important
to those are wonderful ways to
contribute but I am at my core an
outdoor guy III knew when I was 12 years
old back in 1970 I saw on my parents
little black-and-white TV you know back
in the day you got ABC CBS NBC or PBS
that was it I saw in 1970 on that little
black-and-white TV the National
Geographic special on the pioneering
grizzly
research being done in Yellowstone Park
by John and Frank Craighead and I said
to myself at 12 years of age I want to
do that and I would have you believe Tim
that I might have bested that Craig
heads about 18 years later I was in
Yellowstone National Park I was studying
a large carnivore but not one that was
naturally occurring but uncommon Craig
heads and grizzly bears I was actually
working to restore a species that had
been extirpated so this was a fire in my
belly since I was 12 years of age and we
are gonna talk about wolves but I want
to get their visa v a few other species
or at least one other species and maybe
some macro issues you mentioned twelve
years of age
you've obviously done a lot since age 12
and we won't be able to cover all of the
stories and all of the studies but I
have some notes in front of me and I
have bullets for prompting certain
things and I actually don't know any of
these stories so there's one that
clearly popped out and caught my eye
because it sounds so odd and I quote I'm
sure that the students in the dorm would
be willing to donate use tampons to
grizzly bear research what what is the
context on this well not Tim we are
talking about women in Alaska so but
back in the day back in the early 1980s
there was this sense that menstrual odor
menstruating women shouldn't hike in
grizzly bear country and interestingly
enough there was some research that
showed that menstrual fluid actually the
blood from menstrual fluid elicited as
strong a response in polar bears as the
odor of their primary prey that ring
seal so as I was building out my
graduate research I thought well maybe
Jack could somehow test this on grizzly
bears and I thought if I could get women
to help me they would donate used
tampons I would then take the tampon and
I would distill from that mostly blood
but the menstrual fluid and then I would
take that fluid and I was going to
create these little the story gets more
interesting as we go I was going to take
that uh and with a small Rock I was
going to take a small rock and I was
going to affixed to the rock a
in a proper amount of Spagna moss
something that wood or cotton something
that I could then dip in paraffin and
create a small waxy ball that I could
then take the menstrual fluid and inject
into the small ball that was designed to
be fired from a crossbow so that when
hit the ground near the grizzly bear the
little ball would the paraffin would
blow up and expose the missile missile
and of course we'd have we would have
had placebos in we would have shot water
and we would have shot you know there
was concern that toothpaste got grizzly
bears all excited so it was an attempt
to see just what kind of behavior could
be elicited from grizzly bears odors
from non-food items and we were most
intrigued about whether menstruating
women should hike in grizzly bear
country as it turned out I wasn't able
to get funding for the study there was
some concern that I wouldn't be good
enough with my crossbow I love that that
was the crossbow and the work would have
been done in Denali Park and and there
was some you know concern that visitors
would see me shooting crossbows grizzly
bears thinking I might be trying to hurt
him when when in fact I was so probably
I would have done the work deep in the
backcountry and and then there was some
concern about safety because you know
crossbow is a pretty powerful weapon and
it could be a pretty good delivery tool
but still I'd have to be relatively
close and I'm purposely sort of
agitating the bear to see if I can
elicit up a anyway to make a long story
short the study never got funded yeah
what is the what is the in your mind the
the craziest study that you have gotten
funded oh the craziest study out Tim
that's easy buddy so when we let Red
Wolves go back in mid-1980s these were
all captive born animals and I was
intrigued by the notion how would they
transition to life in the wild how would
they transition from a life in captivity
where they were fed for example to a
life of self-sufficiency in the wild and
so I got up with the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission and a friend of mine and we
developed these radioactive shards
radioactive shards it looked like a
little piece of glass
that we could implant subcutaneously
between the shoulder blades of the Red
Wolves just a small incision tuck it
under the skin so up the incision and so
we making that Red Wolves radioactive so
that when they would [ __ ] on the road
and I pick up their scats I could I
could identify a scat to an individual
based on the radioactive signature and I
could look at how individual wolves
males and females with a known history
coming out of captivity how they
individually transition to life in the
wild to a life of self-sufficiency how
did they scent mark I mean we know gray
wolves are so very social they'll
advertise their presence through scent
marks either urine or or feces scat sore
[ __ ]
and so I purposely made red wolves
radioactive so I feel like in the in the
study that didn't get funded you're
trying to be some type of ecological
ninja with the crossbow and here in this
one you're you're turning animals into
x-men yes we got that we got that I may
be the only wild eye biologist well not
but one of the few wildlife biologists
that had radioactive material showed up
on my doorstep in this leadbox with a
permit from the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission that's incredible yeah it was
a good study I'd like to test a what
might be an urban myth on you but having
spent some time in Alaska and so on very
common for people to pack a firearm of
some type for defense with a grizzly I
had I had heard a a story could be made
up but that at some point they took
rangers them really struggling for vocab
here but they took something like six or
ten of them and they had a barrel that
they affixed to a line in a shooting
range if this is making any sense so
they could have the barrel go from far
away towards the person with say a 40
caliber handgun and if something like 9
out of 10 missed this barrel when it was
sent straight at them and then they did
they replicated the experiment with a
large canister of bear spray and perhaps
not surprisingly
everybody managed to hit this barrel
that was that was careening towards them
what are the most effective deterrence
or defensive tools with respect to
Grizzlies yeah you know when I did my
work with Grizzlies in the farc tic it
was back in the 80s there was no bear
spray back in the day but we wouldn't
carry handguns we carried shotguns and
on more than one occasion I should have
been killed by grizzly bears I'm really
fortunate to be here I got lucky I got
lucky because I I made some bad
decisions and put myself in a
compromised position and if the bear had
beat me up it would have been completely
my fault and it was such a remote City
area that I wouldn't have been a chute
man I probably never would have been
found but nonetheless so today here's
what we know is what we know about
grizzly country bear spray works you got
to keep it at the ready so you want it
holstered on your belt you want to
practice with some placebo cans so
because when when when the [ __ ] goes
down and you've got to act you don't
want to be acting for the first time
novelty can kill and you want out you
want to hike with unawareness you want
to pay attention to where you are you
want to pay attention to your
surroundings you want to be cautious
when you go into an area where the view
[ __ ] is limited there's great value in
hiking in a group I don't know of any
cases where a group of hikers that's for
strong or more has been has been
confronted with a physical encounter
with grizzly bears mindful most of these
encounters nearly all of them it's not
the grizzly bears fault they're startled
they're scared they're frightened they
just react and so you should be mindful
that you're probably at fault use your
bear spray if there's going to be
physical contact you do not want to
fight back in a case like that you want
to protect soft parts and you want to
lay still as hard as you can you don't
want to move you don't want to fight
back almost all the time Tim the bear
will beat you up a bit and they'll leave
you alone and they'll leave the
exception to that is if the bear comes
into your tent if the Bears coming into
your tent that's different behavior that
could be considered predatory behavior
you want to fight as hard as you can
fight in that situation because that
bear has a different motive but the
fact is folks grizzly bears are no
reason not to go enjoy your great big
wild country they're a magnificent part
of the world you give them half a chance
they're going to avoid you they don't
want anything to do with you you don't
represent anything but trouble so for
heaven's sakes hike smart I can group's
be prepared with bear spray but for
heaven's sakes above all else go hike so
if you're hiking just to clarify and you
startle say a female grizzly with a cub
and you get charged is the move to just
drop and go into the fetal position is
is that the most appropriate response if
you don't have bear spray let's just
yeah if you don't have bear spray and
she's coming get down yeah now bears
will false charge
I've been party to that the false charge
they'll stop they'll start stomping on
their front legs they're clearly
agitated they'll start they'll start
whooping at you and chomping their gums
when they do that they're really upset
they're really frustrated and and and
lots of times these false charges Tim
while serious don't result in physical
contact but what you just described you
want to get down you want to accept
whatever's coming
protect your soft spots to the best of
your ability and and and if the data
mean anything she'll give up and and
she'll leave you alone and and you can
wait and she'll leave and you can get up
and go get help just one more thing Tim
if people are hiking in grizzly country
another thing that is always a good idea
if you stay on established trails
the grizzly bears know where those
trails are they they know where the
people are they know that you don't
represent anything but a bunch of
trouble and and so if you're where
you're supposed to be and they know it
that's another way to head your best my
lord my family and I have camped along
Yellowstone Lake in the park and we'll
wake up in the morning and move out of
camp to the main trail 30 yards away and
there's first grizzly bear tracks right
on the trail and the bear the bear knew
we were in camp and that knew that there
was nothing there we that people have
for a long time now kept clean camps and
if you do go off of the established
trails if you're excited by bushwhacking
I know I am then I'm especially careful
to keep an eye out
I listen I look if I'm in a restricted
view shed I go slow I sometimes sing I
got a Jerry Jeff Walker tune that I sing
in grizzly bear country that would scare
anything away so yes if some that's some
more good advice I think Tim very good
advice and I've been taking notes
because I do spend time in bear country
but I think I've taken enough notes for
now on bears specifically now I'd like
to segue back to large predators and
ecosystems in general I'll mention also
to people listening just a little bit of
context which is that I want it to be a
marine biologist for 15 years or so and
grew up on Long Island where the at the
time the rod and reel record for great
white sharks had been set and in fact
the crazy shark hunter in Jaws was based
on a guy named Frank Mundus
who lived out on the east end in Montauk
so I had this fascination with with
sharks specifically and spent a lot of
my time looking at sharks which later
much after I decided to take different
career paths reemerged and or re-emerged
rather with introduction to scientists
operating mostly off of different
Caribbean islands who are doing shark
tagging and looking at the effects the
top down effects of apex predators on
various ecosystems could you talk to us
just a little bit about the the effects
and some of these get exaggerated by by
some folks on the sort of conservation
front but nonetheless could you describe
what role large predators or predators
have in an ecosystem where do they fit
what happens if you extra pay it as you
said if you if you wipe out any apex
predator and an ecosystem well the
system the
seriously compromised and and here's why
and we don't have to make reference to
complicated science we can just make it
simple common-sense really matters so
let's let's let's start with the premise
that life is the most important force in
the universe it seems like a reasonable
thing to - to assume we know life is
powerful we know we know that we know
that's this great drive to find its way
forward well that's the case then death
has to be almost as equally powerful and
if you are a species you're an organism
you're an individual that survives by
delivering death
you have to count there's just no way it
works it works otherwise now now that
said for some of these ecological
effects to be manifest the carnivore in
question whether it's a great white
shark or a gray wolf for them to serve
as ecological engineers for them to
perform this mighty important role of
delivering death they have to be common
enough for a long enough period of time
to matter just quite simply Tim one gray
wolf in Yellowstone National Park for
one day does not make a whit of eka
logical difference but but now imagine
oh about a hundred gray wolves in the
park over the course of twenty plus
years that begins to create this change
this change that leads to us a system
that's healthier more resilient more
diverse more capable of perpetuating
itself going forward if life matters
then so too does death and if you are a
deliverer of death you have to matter
what is what is a trophic cascade and
and and then I'd like to go from that to
a discussion of the reintroduction of
gray wolves to Yellowstone National Park
and perhaps you could just give us a
basic overview of what that is yeah and
then know that that's a great question
Tim thinking it's easy trophic just just
a word that refers you can imagine that
the food pyramid and and a trophic
cascade is when species at the top of
the pyramid relatively uncommon animals
like gray wolves begin to have such a
profound effect on the next section next
layer of the food pyramid that those
consequences cascade down through the
rest of the pyramid so for example if
there's enough gray wolves in place
killing enough elk in Yellowstone Park
and causing elk to change their behavior
the reduction in elk numbers and the
change in behavior can bring about
cascading effects through that food
pyramid by changing the vegetative
structure of the system you can see more
willows in parts of Yellowstone Park you
can see more Aspen in parts of
Yellowstone Park those woody species
have had a chance to experience a
release a liberation if you will because
there aren't quite so many elk keeping
them at 2 or 3 inches above the ground
through heavy browsing but rather those
Aspen and Willis can grow up and as they
grow up system there's other wide
effects in the system pasture and birds
become more common no Dickie birds that
migrate from the Neotropics to the
Northern Rockies and back again all of
that woody structure of an aspen forest
for example provides great habitat for
those pasture and birds
the increase in willow can provide
forage for beavers that can now make a
goal that when they couldn't before
so because the gray wolf uncommon is
impacting a relatively more common prey
species in a manner that causes other
parts of the system to change that's
that's where you get this cascading
effect through the trophic system
through the food chain through the food
pyramid
that's all it speaks to there's a rhythm
to nature and if you remove one piece
the rhythm can be interrupted and the
reason thank you very much how the
reason that I wanted to to bring that up
well the reason I suppose is is actually
a collection of reasons the first is
that I think I like many people have
assumed in the past that a if you are
interested in supporting or restoring
ecosystems that you start from the
ground up right so you go from sort of
smallest to largest if that makes sense
and what what I'm hearing and I want you
to correct me if I'm wrong because I'm
gonna work through a lot of stuff that I
don't yet understand of course is that
we're there while there may be many
valid approaches for say restore it or
restoring soil and so on and working
from the ground up that you can also and
must also pay attention to the sort of
top down effects that include carnivores
and the and and like you said the
browsing patterns of the feeding
patterns of these herbivores like elk
which otherwise might be concentrated in
certain areas isn't as concentrated when
you reintroduce the natively previously
natively occurring predators is that
accurate is that yeah yes is that act
yeah yeah of course it is you've got and
it's it's pretty logical one of the
reasons that you start with something
like a gray wolf they're absent you know
gray wolves used to be very common in
the country back in the day they were
the most common large mammal in the
United States you could find grey wolves
from coast to coast east to west and and
north to south you could find him on the
grasslands you can find him in the for
she could find him in the swamp she
could find him in them deserts they were
widely distributed and we launched a war
on the gray wolf that lasted home she
whizzed him 300 years and eventually why
why was the why was the war launched
yeah I think
that are early the early settlers of
this country the European settlers had
this sofa zealots embrace of a manifest
destiny to tame the wilderness we had to
make the land predictable so it could
deliver for us and one way to promote
predictability is to remove those pieces
that operate against their own set of
sensibilities you can remove wild and
self-willed nature from any landscape
and it becomes more predictable far less
interesting far less diverse at the the
long run far less capable of supporting
humanity but nonetheless in the short
run you might think oh this is better
this is better country now that we don't
have gray wolf sin it's better country
now that we don't have bison and in
better country that we don't have
Indians anymore we're going to tame this
landscape we're gonna make it work for
us and that is fundamentally the essence
of the manifest destiny that settled
this country we simply were zealots
determined to wring the wildness out of
this country and my gosh Tim if you can
find a better symbol of wildness than
gray wolves I'd like to know what it
what it is so they got rid of gray
wolves on purpose they got rid of gray
wolves on purpose because it didn't fit
their sense of what this landscape this
great country should be how did how did
that I mean the numbers I don't know
what the numbers are but they must be
staggering I mean the number of wolves
that were killed how does one implement
that type of mass extermination well
it's not it's not done by folks with you
know 22 rifles in their backyard picking
off one or two at a time I mean there's
it was there some systematic approach to
it now there certainly was now first and
foremost the approach was applied with
great determination the approach was
durable it extended across centuries and
for a long time the approach was
supported and actively implemented by
the federal government and there were a
lot of gray wolf shot hundreds of
thousands of probably well into millions
of gray wolves were shot they were
trapped
dens were located puppies were dragged
out of Dems and clubbed to death there
were lots of murders means applied to
whip the wolf but what really pushed the
war to conclusion and pushed the gray
wolf to the brink of extinction in the
continental United States was broadcast
use of poison gray wolves can get pretty
smart and they can avoid traps and they
can avoid getting shot and and they can
dent in tough to find places but boy you
start spreading poison across the
landscape and lace carcasses and my gosh
the gray wolves just don't have a
response to that you know Tim by the
late 1950s you'd taken this most common
carnivore that's really quite easy to
coexist with we're taking this most
common carnivore by the late 1950s you
could only find a few hundred left in
them for northeastern corner of
Minnesota in the Superior National
Forest and the Boundary Waters Canoe
Area so when I began my work with gray
wolf's in 1980 wasn't long after they
had first been listed under the
Endangered Species Act in the mid 1970s
it was nearly a low point when I began
the work my work I worked in Minnesota
my first opportunity there might have
been maybe a thousand gray wolves on the
ground but they were nowhere else since
that low point in the mid 70s many of us
have been working tirelessly over the
last many decades to restore the gray
wolf to suitable habitat so it's no
longer threatened or endangered with
extinction we will definitely have time
to talk about that and as as as you
mentioned it it certainly appears to be
maybe not the only missing piece but one
of the last missing pieces and so we are
going to circle back to why that's
important and why it's time-sensitive
and I certainly feel strongly about that
and I don't I I have the luxury of
waiting for fat pitches as Warren
Buffett would put it in the sense that I
don't I don't take a lot of shots
and I remember a friend of mine who
actually long ago worked for a governor
of a large state he said to me when we
were having pizza and wine one time as
as I was feeling torn among many
different causes and opportunities and
obligations and invitations and so on he
said you should just imagine that you
have a six-shooter on your hip that has
six bullets and you get to shoot six
bullets per year meaning you get to
spend that ammo on things that are on
things that are worthwhile and I suppose
could be pun intended in this case but
I've decided that what you're talking
about is is is how I want to spend at
least one of those rounds so we're going
to come back to it but what what I want
to do first if it's okay with you is to
rewind the clock just a little bit
because that the video that in some ways
led to us talking has been criticized as
as being overly simplistic and so on
which is how wolves change rivers which
people can find on YouTube it's been
viewed more than 40 million times maybe
50 at this point nonetheless it shows
visually what you were describing in
terms of trophic cascade and you are
someone who had boots on the ground and
in the sense that in 86 you started
serving as the first leader of the Red
Wolf restoration program which which we
could certainly get to and then in 1994
the first leader of the Yellowstone gray
wolf restoration program how did you end
up doing that and what what happened in
Yellowstone well it's a long story as to
how I got to lead the Red Wolf program
in the southeast which was for folks
listing they should note it was the
first attempt in the history of mankind
to restore a carnivore species that have
been declared extinct in the wild it is
a fascinating story but because I had I
had done good work and I had established
relationships with people that that
came to know they could count on me and
and I'd have you believed him the best
way forward in life is to not let people
down so they know they can count on you
well in the Yellowstone project popped I
had friends in high places and they knew
they could count on me and so I was able
to lead the Yellowstone project hell I
didn't even apply for the job it was
simply an interagency transfer that Fish
and Wildlife Service just shuffled me
from the Red Wolf program off to the
National Park Service for the
Yellowstone program both agencies
operating under the Department of
Interior which helped and so we did go
forward in 1995 we began building that
reintroduction program animals were
released in 1995 and I can tell you what
Tim when we began the work there were
parts of Yellowstone that were mama
heavens they should have just been an
elk farm there were so many elk in the
system
19,000 animals to be specific on a
stretch of the northern quarter of the
park that's known as the northern range
entirely too many elk I couldn't take a
step on the northern range without
stepping on elk tracks or elk [ __ ] my
lord there were elk everywhere
too many for the system and by the time
we began releasing gray wolves in 1995
and then when the years passed the
system began to change because elk
became less common
they started behaving differently I was
in the park just yesterday visiting one
of the old acclamation pens where the
ecological consequences of predation are
most manifest and there is an
acclamation pen well in Yellowstone Park
we would bring the wolves from Canada
and in Yellowstone we put them in pens
so they could grow acclimated to the
release site it took about 80 or 90 days
before we thought ready for release
so yesterday I went back to one of these
acclamation sites
my Lords Tim it could not be more
different over the last 20 years than if
it tried it is now supports this rich
robust Aspen forest it supports a rich
robust willow community that lines this
active beaver stream none of that was in
place 20 years ago
of course that video has been watched 40
million times because you know nature
can be pretty dramatic and that's a
beautiful portrayal that largely gets it
right
predators matter predators matter now in
Yellowstone to be fair gray wolves made
a big contribution but so do grizzly
bears and so do black bears and so do
Cougars and so do coyotes predators
matter and they matter because they help
ensure that there's a depth there's a
breadth to any particular system you
could go back one of the greatest
ecologist of all time a gentleman named
Aldo Leopold Manny he wrote this essay
entitled thinking like a mountain and he
was the first to poetically observe that
only the mountain has lived long enough
to understand the howl of the wolf only
the mountain knows that too many elk is
a big problem and the only way to
address too many elk is to make sure
you've got good predators in place doing
their job if life matters so too does
death it's fascinating it's fascinating
the way nature is stitched together it
is redundant and it is hard to
understand but sometimes it reaches up
and smacks us upside the head and says
holy mackerel Wolf's can change rivers
you you see you were in a leadership
position with this reintroduction I when
did you when did you leave the project
or when did you leave yeah the the work
in Yellowstone National Park yeah that's
a great question thank you because it
was a very difficult period in my life I
left the park in the early summer of
1997 and you might think what key tell
me you wanted to work there since you
were 12 years old you land in the park
in the fall of 94 and by early summer 97
you're gone that's not much of a shift
well here's what happened I had grown
fascinated about the role of private
land and private assets to advance the
recovery of endangered species because -
wolves - wolves showed me private land
matters one was a little wolf in the
southeastern United States known as 351
the first red wolf born in the wild and
decades and by the time we finally got
around to studying 3:51 realized she's
spent most of her time not on the
Alligator River National Wildlife Refuge
but rather on private land and then fast
forward to my time in Yellowstone of
another young wolf known as number three
right after release from the great
assemblage of public lands that is
Yellowstone in the national forests that
surround the park number three went to
private land and I began to think holy
mackerel even in the big Western public
landscapes of Montana and Wyoming and
Idaho private land can matter in in 1995
I had the good fortune of meeting Ted
Turner Ted is a hero of mine and he is a
great big slice of Americana bigger than
life with a great big heart and a even
bigger imagination and Ted and I over
the course of about 18 months found a
way forward that together we could
illustrate beyond doubt the power of
private land and private assets employed
in collaboration with state and federal
governments to advance the restoration
of imperiled species as a bonafide
redress for the extinction crisis which
is a crisis and we need to speak to that
today Tim because it's the ultimate
backdrop for all of this work but I left
the park in 97 to co-found with Ted
Turner the Turner and dangered species
fund intern of biodiversity divisions
they have from day one stood has the
most significant private effort in the
world to use reintroductions to restore
imperiled plants birds fishes mammals
amphibians reptiles on and on I'm so
proud to be a member of Team Turner well
let's let's talk about let's talk about
the extinction crisis because this is a
backdrop as you said and you know what
one of the things that I strive very
hard to do is understand multiple
perspectives and positions as related to
any issue and when it comes to say
predators for a whole host of reasons
that will probably get into
the conversations can become very heated
and very divisive very quickly so very
early on one of the questions that I
sent to scientists and that would
include you is well I'll just read it
I'll just read a couple of the questions
but then we'll focus on one so I asked
as related to a couple of things what
decisions are time-sensitive in the next
handful of months that really matter if
any what next question what are
worthwhile and measurable goals to have
like in the sort of what gets measured
gets managed to camp of thinking then I
had talked about points of greatest
leverage impact long-term effects I also
asked this is the one I wanted to
highlight what do well-intentioned
people on the conservation
reintroduction side get wrong or say
that makes them look ridiculous or
uninformed and the reason I'm using that
as a segue is that as a non non
biologist non scientist myself I've
heard people say well species go extinct
all the time which is certainly true
right so what what makes what you see in
the field from the data and so on
different from the normal Evan flow of
species just not hacking it in the
broader sweep of of evolution and
natural selection oh it's the pace have
changed him of course extinction is
simply the death of a species and that's
happened since the dawn of time but it's
the rate of change and the scale of
change so let's think about that for but
I want to go back you asked one question
what what Oh conservationists get wrong
and we speak about the extinction crisis
here's the one thing that everybody gets
wrong that humans could go extinct
humans aren't going to go extinct humans
and cockroaches and coyotes are going to
inherit the earth now it may not be an
earth worth living on and it could be
masses of people that lead lives of
outrageous desperation not not a wife
that your IRA or anyone else would
choose to live
but they're still living they're still
alive there's still a sentient
carbon-based organisms out there trying
to make ends meet III I think what we're
doing is so deeply filing our nest that
we've got a serious problem so that's
that's the one thing that we that we get
wrong but back to your question the the
real startling fact now is the pace of
change and the scale of change so across
500 million years this planet has
supported multicellular life and across
those five hundred million years there
have been five previous great extinction
crises the first occurred about 435
million years ago during the Ordovician
era the most recent one occurred about
65 million years ago during the
Cretaceous era when an asteroid slammed
into the planet off the coast of what is
now the Yucatan Peninsula measuring
something like six miles across and
traveling at something like forty-five
thousand miles an hour and in a
geological instant Tim that asteroid
ended the reign of the dinosaurs
well now the sixth great extinction
crisis began during the Anthropocene era
the era of man and the Anthropocene
began in the late 18th century if not
centuries earlier the the current
extinction crisis is worldwide species
are disappearing at probably a thousand
times faster than the background rate
that you would assume if things were
more settled and in this case it's not a
speeding asteroid that's causing the
problem but rather it's us with this
relentless pursuit of dominating the
planet for one end to advance the cause
and the prospects of humanity so I would
say to you and all your listeners no
matter who you are the extinction crisis
should matter let's assume for a moment
that you're a person of faith how can
you love the creator and not love the
creation and how can you stand by and
watch something you love be destroyed
needlessly without rising up in defense
or let's assume for a moment that you're
a secular humanist
and you believe rather than faith its
facts and data and logic and empiricism
that matter well Tim the best science
tells us that the fate of humanity has
always been and will always be decided
by the health of local landscapes the
world over the extinction crisis makes
clear those landscapes are not the least
bit healthy we continue down this path
at our great peril
thank you and I have to ask you do you
ever have days when you are just
overwhelmed by the magnitude and seeming
acceleration and growth of behaviors by
humans that just seem unstoppable I mean
I I am certainly trying to be a force
for good in whatever small way I can be
in the world but it's I sometimes feel
like I'm that with a girl and the
apocryphal story of walking down the
beach with thousands of starfish laying
on the beach more and more getting
washed up and she's throwing in wanted
one at a time every few minutes and
somebody walks by and says what do you
think you can save them all it doesn't
matter and she doesn't matter so this
one it throws the next one in right but
there are times when and I know that
some of my friends feel this way as well
it's it just seems like a foregone
conclusion that we are going to as you
put it just foul the nest and destroy
our environment to the point that it's
irrecoverable and it's like if people
continue to have sex continue to buy
lots of plastic continue to behave in
the ways that they're behaving which are
fairly understandable in some respects
because everyone is self-interested in
response to incentives mostly short-term
how do you how do you how do you digest
that type of feeling or overcome it
because it is something that comes up
for me I'm not gonna lie well
a couple of things is a great question I
I know from my own work over now going
on 40 years that restoration is an
alternative to extinction I know that I
know that we can choose to be different
I know that we often act as misguided
gods but I also know that we can choose
to act otherwise and when I was a little
kid I was six and seven and eight and
nine when I was becoming me my family
really only did one thing man I'll tell
you what Tim we played baseball my dad
played pro ball before I was born and my
brothers and I played baseball I played
baseball until I was 20 years old I was
gonna play professional baseball that
was what was gonna move me forward and
when you looked at how I played the game
I was always the kind of kid that helped
manufacture runs my brothers were deeply
gifted athletes they just showed up and
they were rock stars the only thing the
good Lord gave me was the capacity to
practice I could practice the [ __ ] out
of that game I'd be out there early and
I'd stay late and I just learned through
my own youth that manufacturing runs
just working with great determination is
a way forward that I found deeply
satisfying you combine that with my
awareness that restoration is an
alternative to extinction and my deep
belief that the world is run by those
who show up I wake up every morning
ready to go so you have you have hope
then I mean you're not I have
determination I think that's more
important than hope yeah but my fear is
that I have some hope too because I've
recognized that if you believe in a God
if you believe in a God and I know a lot
of your listeners are probably people of
faith I think that that that if if there
is a God what she gave us was that this
great right to choose we can choose to
be different we can choose to celebrate
the importance of wild and self-willed
nature we don't have to continue or the
way we've been we can choose to be
different and that's what motivates me
that's what gives me hope I know that
choice is a reality
yeah determination is is more important
than hope I remember it's probably 2009
or so I'm gonna say 2009 2010 when I
received as a gift a staff shirt from
the production of the movie Avatar
and Jim Cameron is he's a very smart guy
he's very intense he's very determined
and known for having grueling
productions in part because they're so
ambitious and as as he put it he's been
on the podcast before that he knew it
was going to be the most difficult movie
production in history very most likely
and so he gave all of the staff shirts
which had a quote on the chest and the
very first line was hope is not a
strategy on one day there you go there
yes and and this is speaking of strategy
like the the way that this conversation
came together the way we met is it's
pretty wild just given all the factors
that at play but let's talk about
Colorado for for a minute and we're
gonna zoom in and out so we're not gonna
do just Colorado but I don't live in
Colorado I live in Texas and I've
certainly spent time in the great state
of Colorado and I love it you guys have
wonderful wildlife fantastic skiing I
should also point out that I've I've
gone to Colorado to hunt I do not oppose
certain types of hunting that which is
also why I was in the the Brooks Range
it's a beautiful state and all of that
as backdrop I was not aware of the
significance of Colorado when it comes
to
this this keystone species if I'm using
it correctly that we call the gray wolf
could you could you describe why
Colorado is in some ways the the last
missing piece well because I I certainly
did not know any of this and then it
caught caught my imagination for a
Lottery's well I certainly can and one
reason that he didn't know about it is
this story that is the mother lode of
opportunity for wolves in western
Colorado has has not been told well
western Colorado possesses certain
characteristics that are just superbly
suited for the gray wolf Rick
principally among those attributes
there's over 17 million acres of federal
public lands in western Colorado so Tim
it doesn't matter that you live in Texas
doesn't matter that your listeners live
all across the country listeners all
across the world at least for folks in
this country what matters is those are
your national forests the the the White
River National Forest is just as much
your national force whether you live in
Denver or Austin it doesn't matter
that's the whole point of federal public
lands western Colorado is graced with
over 17 million acres of federal public
lands and across those federal public
lands they support 700,000 an estimated
700,000 deer and elk after after the
recreational hunter has removed about
80,000 deer and elk there remain on the
ground about 700,000 when you look at
what makes wolf recovery successful you
need a big patch of federal public lands
that's the 17 plus million acres and you
need a big prey population that's the
700,000 Darren elk it is a biological
mother load on top of that Coloradans
have a sensibility that that's different
than many states Colorado and celebrate
their wildness Coloradans have indicated
over decades that they would they would
willingly welcome the war
home and then finally I would have you
believe from an ecological and symbolic
standpoint restoring the gray wolf to
the great state of Colorado does a good
job of helping to restore that state's
natural balance and it would serve as
the arch stone the final piece Tim the
final piece of the restoration puzzle
that connects gray Wolf's from the High
Arctic all the way to the Mexican border
there's no other place in the world and
you could imagine restoration of a much
maligned misunderstood persecuted large
carnivore over such a continental and
sweeping scale that is restoration magic
of the finest kind both the wolf action
fun.com and the Rocky Mountain wolf
project.org
are trying to move that idea forward to
ensure that the gray wool finds its way
back to its ancestral homelands in
western Colorado and what we'll talk
also about the the organization's and
I'll link to those in the show notes for
everybody but let me let me paraphrase
what what I heard in that last portion
of what you said because it's it's part
of what drew my attention to all of this
that we're discussing is it's actually
I'll ask Alice get is a question is it
fair to say that nowhere else in the
world exists an opportunity to
reestablish a major carnivore at a
continental scale as does this
opportunity in Colorado yes that is that
an accurate statement yes okay and this
is that exciting isn't that exciting my
lord it is exciting and I'll tell you
part of what makes it so appealing to me
so we talked about trophic cascade we
talked about the importance of this type
of top-down impact already and in how
necessary that is we also talked about
how as you put it
you've been drawn to the rarity of of
carnivores and
that the reason that rare is it draws my
attention is not only because there may
be a in many instances certainly with
the gray wolf a a a lack of sufficient
numbers but also that you don't need to
reintroduce millions of wolves to have a
tremendous tremendous impact on positive
impact on natural ecosystems you don't
need tens of thousands as you put it if
you look at this pyramid at the very top
you have much smaller numbers than at
the bottom so a to if we're looking at
the opportunity to re-establish a major
carnivore at a continental scale how
many wolves need to be reintroduced over
what period of time for that to stand a
very good chance of being realized oh
not many Tim you're absolutely right
buddy it would be over the course of
maybe two years maybe three if you were
to translocate
oh she was fifteen twenty wolves a year
over the course of a couple of years
from say Montana to Colorado you let him
go they take care of the rest and rather
short order let's say within a decade
those twenty thirty forty wolves that
you move from translocated from Montana
released in Colorado they give rise to a
population that would be approaching a
hundred strong we could assume for this
discussion that a viable population
would be something like two hundred and
fifty wolves you you would see that
probably within the first 15 years or so
maybe twenty years after release and it
would get there with a great deal of
certainty we've done this work before
it's exactly what we did in the northern
Rocky Mountains we know how to do this
cost-effectively we know how to do it
certainly and most importantly we know
how to do it humanely what what do you
hope the the ripple effects would be of
this if it
done right because for a lot of people
listening they might say if they don't
have some great affinity for the wolf
for some reason which a lot of people
don't what are the what are the
beneficial larger-scale effects that are
plausible outside of the repopulating of
wolves themselves by doing that if such
an initiative were successful what would
you hope some of the ripple effects to
be well Tim thank you because ultimately
that's why I wake up as I said every day
excited determined to try to do a little
more than my fair share
I believe that restoring gray Wolf's to
western Colorado has tremendous power as
an accomplishment it would make clear
that wolf restoration provides a new way
of relating to nature a new way for us
to go forward to help in and the
senseless destruction of the natural
world through thoughtful purposeful
well-designed reintroduction projects as
a conservation scientist him who is
keenly aware of the growing magnitude of
the extinction crisis and which spoke to
that moments ago I know that restoration
efforts that inspire people are
essential taking humanity's well-being
lest we continue to grow increasingly
disconnected from our evolutionary past
and divorce from a relationship with the
natural world that promises peace
prosperity and justice for not only
human life but but non-human life and I
want to emphasize so your listeners
there there's no equivocation here they
should make no doubt that the stakes are
high and growing ever more so we spoke
about the sixth great extinction crisis
it's tightening its grip on the planet
compromising all that is really
important but what restoration reminds
us that we can choose to be something
other than misguided gods it it
illustrates how we can change it makes
clear that restoration is an alternative
to extinction
why why is this controversial and I'm
I'm asking mostly for people listening
because I've looked into this a lot but
I'd love for you to speak to why wolf
recovery is so divisive I mean in this
day and age I would hope people to be
past the Little Red Riding Hood image of
kind of fairy tale all-powerful evil
wolf archetypes but it's a carnivore I
get it like it I would not want to be
eaten by wolves wouldn't want all my
livestock to be eaten by wolves mean
there are a lot of concerns but why is
it so charged and so divisive and could
you could you speak to sort of real
versus justified versus unjustified
concerns yeah well you know it's a
problem wolf restoration is a problem
wolf restoration is controversial its
divisive because people embrace the
mythical wolf people believe that the
wolf far too many people believe that
the wolf has an almost supernatural
ability to exercise its predatory will
on a whim and consequently wolves create
this wake of death and desolation and
destruction wherever they go
and yet Tim the real wolf the real wolf
is not even a shadow of its mythical
self unfortunately the myth is as strong
and is is wrong for the real wolf oh my
lord life is a daily struggle to survive
for the real wolf starvation is a common
cause of death for the real wolf I
didn't even build well for the job at
hand Tim they're not well suited to
their predatory lifestyle their body's
not well built for the job they always
kill things but they live on things
bigger than themselves even a small
white-tailed deer
tends to be bigger than a gray wolf even
if gray wolves weighed on average a
hundred pounds or 90 pounds a small
weight white-tailed deer weighs more
than that
their nose their nose is not well built
for the task at hand that long nose
ensures that the the biting power at the
tips of the canines is much reduced
compared to say a shorter nose of a
cougar their teeth how she wish you know
their teeth wear down and break a
beavers teeth you may not know this but
listeners may not know what a beavers
teeth or ever-growing if you're annoying
rodent having teeth that growth in your
entire life that's that's a good thing
that's not the case for a gray wolf
their legs their legs are great for
traveling there's an old Russian proverb
that says a wolf escaped fed by its feet
well that's a it's a good gray Wolf's
can travel great distances but after
that when you look at their legs their
four limbs are not heavily muscled in
contrast to a cougar or a black boar
grizzly bear and the reason being is
that gray wolves front legs don't
supinate they can't reach around and
grab you in contrast to a cougar or
grizzly bear can reach around and grab
you that's why their fore limbs are so
heavily muscled when you look at a
wolf's feet they're there their claws
are decidedly uninteresting they're
always exposed they wear down Oh
gee-whiz a grizzly bear black bear
they've got great big claws a cougar
he's taken the notion of claws to an
extreme by keeping his retracted so then
anytime they're needed boar they're
ready to go they're ready to go let me
pause you for just one sec so I
understand I understand all of that but
I don't want to make wolf sound like
they're they're complete evolutionary
misfires they're pretty well so I'm
getting it okay like unlike unlike
unlike say domesticated dogs I mean the
the less muscular chests allow their
their their forelegs to be more closely
underneath their center of gravity right
so there are benefits oh but it's not
like they just they're not mislead no no
well they're also not super villains so
it's like out of how many hunts would a
a reasonably healthy but not
supernaturally powered wolf pack succeed
in a kill is there any day are there
there's great there's great data on all
these aspects about wolf ecology the
grave
the most studied large mammals in the
world we know a great deal about gray
wolves and what and we know they fail
every time they go hunting Tim they come
up empty part about seven or eight times
out of ten hunting is dangerous
I did a study wolf skulls in Alaska
looked at 225 skulls from animals that
had been shot by Alaska Department of
Fish and Game to minimize predation
pressure on a local caribou population
of our local moose herd so these were
animals that had been shot I was looking
at their skulls for evidence of
blunt-force trauma how often they've
been kicked in the head by a moose for
example Tim fully a quarter of the skull
showed a broken nose broken jaw broken
skull a good friend of mine Ralph Peters
in his study wolves and moose in IRL
since 1972 Roth has never done a
necropsy
which is just an autopsy of an animal
never done a necropsy a wolf that hasn't
shown evidence of blunt-force trauma
broken rib broken leg broken nose here's
the point there life is tough it's
difficult to make a living in the woods
with your teeth they got two things
going for him two things going for him
that make them wonderfully adapted and
successful I said moments ago they were
there were everywhere back in the day
coast to coast east to west north to
south despite all their liabilities they
have two assets that put them in the
green here are the two assets they are
dogged ly determined they wake up every
day and they go to work and for a gray
wolf going to work that means she's got
to put 7 and 10 pounds of food in her
belly a day now they'll go many many
many days with no food at all there's a
feast or famine existence but on average
they got to put the equivalent of 7 to
10 pounds of food in their belly every
day they go to work they're dogged ly
determined the second asset they are
supremely social there's that Rudyard
Kipling poem law of the jungle and
there's two lines in that poem that read
the strength of the pack is the wolf and
the strength of the wolf is the pack
they are dogged ly determined they're
supremely social they are successful
because of those two asset assets
despite all their liabilities but it's
crazy for people to think that wolves
exercise their predatory will on a whim
they don't but because people embrace
that mythical wolf
it's that embrace that gets in the way
of wolf recovery that's why it's okay
travursel they're not willing to
acknowledge the real wolf which the best
available science much of which I've
helped collect says that coexisting with
the gray wolf is a rather
straightforward affair that requires
only a modicum of accommodation so let's
let's talk about the the people who
aren't or are not actually not the
people with the concerns of the people
who are opposed to wolf reintroduction
and I spent a lot of time reading up on
this watching videos because I wanted to
understand their perspective and I
should also say that as as a bit of
context for people listening and I don't
think that you knew this either that I
have family in farming I have supported
American Farmland trust among other
nonprofits related to farmland and so on
since 2011 or 2012 when the 4-hour chef
came out and as I mentioned earlier I
also hunt so that it's it's not as
though I have a stones to cast at-at-at
hunters or farmers and ranchers but
there was there is opposition from from
hunters outdoors men and women who are
concerned that wolves will wipe out big
game or decimate local big-game
populations
you also have ranchers who are very
concerned that wolves will kill their
livestock and
really devastate them economically how
do you how do you respond or how would
you respond to those people well here's
what I say and I've been saying this for
a long time and these statements are
backed up by decades of reliable
research including many papers published
in very good journals so this is really
very reliable science first and foremost
we know the gray wolves are not a threat
to human safety
they just aren't and so we can I never
dismiss anybody's fear if they truly are
concerned about their safety because the
gray wolves their fear is their fear and
they're entitled to it I simply say well
I appreciate your fear it's unfounded
there's nothing that we know that tells
us that that's a justified concern and
then I can tell them countless stories
and I can tell you stories to today that
make clear at least in my life gray
wolves have never ever been a threat so
so that's the human safety issue
wolves and livestock it is true it is
just true again framed by decades of
reliable research it's the atypical wolf
that kills livestock most gray wolves
don't the wolf's depredations and
livestock do not represent a threat to
the livestock industry the depredation
events are just too uncommon for example
in Montana with eight or nine hundred
gray wolves on the ground in Montana
there's about 50 head of cattle killed a
year 50 head of cattle it's out of over
2 million is not a threat to the
industry now if the year 50 had a cattle
you got a problem I acknowledge that
fortunately I know that we have very
good tools at the ready for resolving
conflicts when they arise and very good
tools at the ready forever preventing
conflicts from occurring in the first
place and then as it relates to wolfson
big game and wolves and big-game hunting
I've been a big game hunter I understand
that that recreational pursuit I get
that but here's what we know in
Minnesota Wisconsin Michigan lots of
big-game hunters there and Montana
Wyoming and Idaho
lots of big-game hunters there there's
been no interruption with thousands of
wolves on the ground in the Great Lakes
states and thousands of wolves on the
ground in the northern Rocky Mountains
there's been no interruption of big-game
hunting in those states for years Tim I
served as the ranking minority member of
the Montana House Fish and Game
Committee and then I was the ranking
minority member of the Senate Fish and
Game Committee I saw this not only as a
biologist this issue of wolves in big
game I saw it as a biologist but also I
saw the issue as a as a state
representative and a state senator and
most of the time people were coming to
our committees to express concern about
too many elk most of the elk management
units in the state of Montana are either
at management objective as decided by
Montana fishwife and parks or over
objective for Evans sakes Tim you know
there's areas in Montana where you can
hunt elk six months out of the year
because the state is trying to affect a
population reduction and some of those
areas with that very liberal elk hunting
season is in wolf country there are
simply no data that would support the
claim that gray wolves are going to kill
enough elk or deer to cause the big game
applecart to fall over it's just not
true and I'd finally say to hunters
I can't just celebrate the opportunity
to hunt big game in country where you
have a kindred spirit
doing the same thing don't you find some
kindred connection with another great
predator that being the gray wolf that
in contrast to your prospects if you
fail to kill that deer that elk you're
probably not going to go home and go
hungry in contrast that gray wolf comes
up empty pawed she's going home and
going hungry let's let's talk about a
few of the tools that might help with
reintroduction let's let's tools which
which could be physical could be just
incentive structures let's say wolves
get reintroduced wolves have
reintroduced wolves have been killed in
the past by ranchers through trapping I
mean the the wolves have been released
and then they've been killed it doesn't
always happen but it does happen how do
how how can you minimize the conflict
between wolves and humans what are some
of the practical tactical tools that you
can use to either keep wolves away from
livestock to incentivize
people to not kill wolves or at least to
be compensated if their livestock has
killed me what are some of the
approaches that you think would be most
helpful well and nobody will be
surprised by this but we know the
Shepards matter that they were called
Shepherds back in the day now they're
called range riders but having a
presence in an amongst your livestock
makes a world of difference you can
affect changes in in wolf's movement
patterns across short periods of time by
just being there you can get the wolf to
leave your mob of cattle your mob up she
just ride your horse at them they're
gonna run away so range riders make a
world of difference you can employ
different husbandry practices you can
specifically begin to manage your cattle
for example in a fashion that promotes a
greater degree of herding amongst the
livestock so they stay in bigger groups
that creates defensive opportunities
that wouldn't exist otherwise you can
modify where you're having cabbing take
place that would help to minimize the
exposure of young cattle to gray wolves
you know it's certainly a compensation
program can take the bite out of a
problem so to speak if if you suffer a
loss of a valuable calf because of a
gray wolf you could fairly claim the
right to be paid you had your private
property taken from you by by a public
asset in this case it was a gray wolf
and so we know that compensation
programs help too you know you can even
modify gray wolves movement patterns and
their their behavior a bit by hanging
strips of flagging you might find this
hard to believe but it does work hanging
strips of flagging from a fence
it's called flattery FL ad ry flattery
lo and behold flattery these strips of
flagging hanging from a fence flapping
in the wind creates confusion for a gray
wolf and they tend not to go through the
flattery so you can encompass a cabin
areas with flattery to buy yourself some
security as well because the gray wolves
are bothered by that that flapping
flagging there's lots of techniques that
can be employed to find a way forward
I'll say this and maybe I oversimplify
we can put an astronaut on the moon and
bring her home back again we can take
your heart out of your chest and put it
back better than before I promise you we
can figure out how to coexist with gray
wolves
let me ask just to dig into that a
little bit more playing the role of
Rancher let's say I think humans all
humans including me are prone to look
for the path of least resistance or the
the least amount of work that can do the
most whatever the objective might be so
if I'm a rancher and you mentioned a few
examples of changing herding behavior
calving locations and so on that sounds
like a decent amount of work and
certainly if the herds are really large
I can imagine if the operations get
larger that's that's that's certainly
going to be be the case and maybe it's
even more of an onus for the the smaller
Rancher without as many hands to help
but how do you incentivize that behavior
because if I'm a rancher and I'm not
going to be penalized for shooting a
wolf and I do have that fear of a wolf
killing my livestock a gun and a bullet
are a lot cheaper so and a lot faster a
lot easier I don't have to think about
it as much how do you how do you
incentivize the behavior that you want
in this case how would you suggest we
approach it even if it's just forming a
group to figure out how to approach it
but I always try to look at the
behavioral modification failure points
and I have not done this with ecosystems
but I've certainly done it with tens of
thousands of people trying to follow
diets or stop smoking or fill in the
blank how do you incentivize the
behavior you want if it requires extra
work what a great question Tim thank you
and and first I would point out and I
admit my bias as a state senator I
I hold laws in high regard
recognize that we're a law-abiding
country we're a country founded on laws
laws don't always allow for the path of
least resistance to be followed so for
example it just can't go shoot stuff you
can't just go shoot wildlife we have
laws in this country that say wildlife
are a public trust asset managed by
state and federal agencies for the
public's benefit you don't own the elk I
don't own the elk you just can't go
shoot an elk anytime you want you can't
shoot a gray wolf necessarily anytime
you want that might be the path of least
resistance it happens to be illegal well
if you don't like that okay okay you
could try to change the law but I don't
think anybody would argue that we just
abandoned laws and begin to ignore them
willy-nilly but nonetheless I appreciate
the path of least resistance I know I
tend to follow that path when I can I
have made the point over and over again
that I would be more than willing to
incentivize coexistence with gray wolves
by advocating for very liberal
management on private land
it's your ranch it's your problem you
take care of it we want to make sure
that your response to taking care of us
back by law so you're not a law breaker
but we can do that
shoot the wolf on private land if the
laws would allow for that that's liberal
management I promise you a dead wolf is
not going to get your chicken coop
anymore they wouldn't do that much
anyway but you get the point but in
contrast Tim if you can embrace the
notion of liberal management on private
land the flip side the flip side of that
is very conservative management on
public land now this is land that's
owned by you and me and everyone else
those seventeen plus million acres that
I made reference to earlier in western
Colorado the White River National Forest
for example we own that land that land
is not owned by any one Rancher and we
have subsidized that Rancher extensively
to use that resource we're sharing it
with that rancher by charging that
Rancher a fraction of what that grass is
actually worth just to clarify what
you're saying is that
private ranchers can use public land for
grazing at low cost and that's where you
would you would want to see stronger
rules as related to management yes yes I
mean it's it's not it's not any one
person's land it's the public's land I
could make a case that there's nothing a
gray wolf can do on public land that's
wrong except threaten human life okay
but if you're there subsidized by the
American public to be there you choose
to be there it's a willing choice nobody
put a gun to your head and said your
business model has to rely on using the
public's grass in the national forests
okay okay we're already helping by
charging a fraction of what it's worth
the cost of that money you know Tim
there's no free lunch buddy I've never
found a free lunch in my life the cost
of that money that costed that subsidy
is recognizing that you have less
opportunity to follow that path of least
resistance so I'm all-in on finding a
way forward the ranchers I find their
concerns to be valid even though and I
can share data make clear that it's the
atypical wolf that kills livestock
something like ninety nine point nine
five percent of cattle in the Northern
Rockies are never bothered by gray
wolves it's a very very small point zero
one point zero five percent number of
cattle but if you're the one that just
lost two calves last night you got a
problem and we've got good tools for
resolving that conflict and sometimes I
think we can let people follow the path
of least resistance on private land that
makes sense to me but I'm not sure that
makes sense on public land you mentioned
something earlier that I want to revisit
for a second which is saying that you
can't just shoot say gray wolves or
other species willy-nilly and that's
certainly true in a lot of cases we've
been talking about Colorado
could you talk a little bit about what
is happening right now on a national
level and tell us what ESA stands for
and in this case not emotional support
animal but something else yeah the ESA
in the context of our discussion today
would stand for the Endangered Species
Act it is the bedrock foundation for the
recovery of imperiled species like the
gray wolf absent the Endangered Species
Act there would be no gray wolves in
this country there'd be no grizzly bears
in this country they also need those big
tracts of federal public lands so that
the national voice matters in terms of
deciding their future not just a local
or a private voice but we've talked
about that what the United States
Vishwanath Service has recently done is
move an idea forward a proposal I think
it's misguided the proposal that would
say because of the good work that we've
done with gray wolves in Minnesota
Wisconsin Michigan the work that we've
done in Montana Wyoming and Idaho
principally we don't need to do anything
else anywhere else well I think that's a
an odd misguided interpretation of their
mandated duties under the Endangered
Species Act I don't think the proposal
will be finalized if it is I don't think
the final version will stand up to
traditional scrutiny I think the gray
wolf will continue to be protected under
federal law in places like Colorado as I
said earlier the Rocky Mountain wolf
project and the Rocky Mountain wolf
Action Fund both aim to move the notion
forward of recovering the gray wolf to
this great big patch of opportunity that
is in western Colorado
let me ask just a quick pause and
question how much of its historical
range does the gray wolf currently
inhabit in the continental United States
in the continental United States Tim -
despite decades of hard work and and
I've been honored to be a big part of
that as I mentioned earlier my work
started in 1980 decades of hard work by
deeply determined scientists and
conservationists the gray wolf now still
only claims occupation of about 15% of
its historical range the flipside it
continues to be extirpated extinct from
80
5% of its range let me ask you a
question
that I'd love to hear you take a stab at
I'm sure you have an answer for it which
is why are different animals proposed
for delisting at different points in
their rehab atte ssin of their
historical range in other words if you
had something like the bald eagle I'm
pretty sure that of course it's perhaps
an exception because it's the symbol of
our nation but that's not going to be
taken off the ESA after it's occupying
15% of its historical range and there's
probably a lot between the bald eagle
and the gray wolf but why why is such a
range permissible yeah some species are
simply exhausting I think with the gray
wolf for example the United States Fish
and Wildlife Service is just exhausted
by it they've had enough of it they want
to be done with it so that they're tired
because it's such a hot topic right it's
exhausting it sucks all the oxygen out
of the room it commands a big budget
they've got other other issues to
address their job is a big job and they
find themselves spending a lot of time
with grey wolves and not so much time
with other species that are equally
deserving I would have the service
believe the solution is not to delist
prematurely the solution is for the
United States Congress to properly fund
the Endangered Species Act which it's
never done but interestingly enough and
I've pointed this out to the United
States Fish and Wildlife Service and I
hold that agency Tim in high regard I
was proud when I worked for the
Department of interior's US Fish
Wildlife Service I was proud to wear
that brown uniform but the fact is the
Endangered Species Act doesn't say do
this recovery work until it gets hard
then you can quit that's not in the law
what the law says is go do this hard
work and for a species like the grey
wolf that was very common very
controversial for a lot of unjustified
reasons it's hard to achieve recovery
I've even published in good journals the
simple good science journals
peer-reviewed papers good the simple
observation may be the way the law is
maybe the way the Endangered Species Act
is written maybe the way it defines
recovery it's too much maybe it's too
much for this country maybe we have to
dial it back a bit okay that's a fair
consideration but until the law changes
the United States Fish and Wildlife
Service has to apply a common sense
interpretation of the words of the law
as it goes forward that's what you do on
a law-abiding country it doesn't always
mean you get to follow the path the
police resistance so Mike I'd love to
talk about strategy solutions timelines
all of that because I as I mentioned at
the perhaps midpoint of this
conversation asked a number of questions
to many different scientists including
yourself and one of them was what
decisions are time sensitive in the next
in the next handful of months I said one
two three months but in time sensitive
in the next handful of months that
matter if any worthwhile measurable
goals was another one and then I also
asked where could 25 to 50 K be applied
for the greatest leverage impact or
long-term effects and I had a whole host
of other questions but those were a few
of them what can people do what's what
is happening right now
what are the deadlines and how can
people help and then I'll speak to my
own involvement as well but perhaps you
could just fill people in as to what can
be done and what the time sensitivity is
with the opportunity and just to restate
the opportunity the opportunity is to
capitalize on an opportunity that exists
nowhere else in the world other than in
that fair state of Colorado to
reestablish a major carnivore at a
continental scale I mean that's really
remarkable just but but I'll let you
take it from here
yeah Tim thank you it is remarkable that
you could put the arch stone in place
and connect gray wolves from the High
Arctic to the Mexican border by
restoring a viable population in western
Colorado so the listeners understand
just a little bit of history a few years
ago an educational effort rose up it's
known as the Rocky Mountain Wolf project
I'm honored to serve on the science
advisory team
with other scientists of repute eel
Wilson's a member of the science team
for example and the project sits there
and it says could you just as a pause
because many people might not know who
is who is the Oh Wilson well as I said
II Oh Wilson is also on the science team
I would have you believe ed is he's one
of the greatest biologists who's ever
lived
his work is Darwin s kin scope he was a
professor emeritus at Harvard in this
the world's arguably the greatest world
world's greatest naturalist he's written
several powerful books not to appeal at
surprises he has Pulitzer Prize winner
he has received I think it's the the
ecological award equivalency if the
Nobel Peace Prize Edie is a rock star
and a great hero of mine and Ed's on the
science team but there's other really
good scientists too so here's the point
of the Rocky Mountain Wolf project it
just sent it set out with this simple
aim to say if we can tell the truth
about gray wolves the truth as defined
by decades of reliable research we
believe Coloradans will conclude that
coexisting with the gray wolf was a
straightforward affair that only
requires a modicum of accommodation that
conclusion advances restoration and off
the Rocky Mountain wolf project went it
tried to move the federal government in
the position of action it had some
opportunity to move other conservation
visionaries to action and and the
project had some good success over the
last few years putting out really good
information and telling the truth well
not long ago of early 2019 another group
sprang up it's considered a sibling
organization if you'd like that wants to
bring forth change with a great deal of
certainty that that group is known as
the Rocky Mountain Wolf action fund and
it's a it's a group of conservation
visionaries that recognize the
suitability of gray wolves being
restored to Colorado as an important
part of restoring the state's Natural
Balance the Action Fund aims to put
Wolfe restoration on the 2020 ballot and
elect Coloradans decide whether the wolf
has a future in the state or not the
action fund intends to use direct
democracy to bring forth the
I think the action fund would be excited
and celebrate of an affirmative decision
yes gray wolf should be part of the
future they've got great polling data
over the course of decades that show
Colorado
ants are keenly supportive of this idea
so if you ask me what can be done you
know folks can be mindful of both of
those efforts there is if I may
interrupt that apologize but just since
I know a lot of my listeners are like me
in the sense they're like numbers how
many signatures or dollars do you need
by when to give the reintroduction
effort the greatest chance possible of
success and in this case it relates to
the ballot but like how many signatures
by what dates how much money what is
actually needed you know what I have
seen the action fund put forward
recently is that there's a $600,000 need
by the 15th of September to ensure that
a sufficient number of signatures are
gathered to properly firm the wolf
restoration initiative so that it
appears on the 2020 ballot now it is
admittedly a lot of money but there are
people all over this country that might
want to rise up and say I want to do my
part to restore the ecological integrity
of my national forests so as your
listeners think about this this the
landscape of relevance to this idea is
the landscape that we all own that there
there are national forests and and
restoring the balance of our national
forests is in a is a is an exciting
inspiring endeavor and I believe that if
enough people rose up five dollars here
and twenty five dollars there pretty
soon you're talking real money this is
600 K by September 15th what happens to
that 600 K what does it get used for
well as I understand it the Rocky
Mountain Wolf action fund will use that
money to offset the remaining costs to
ensure that 200,000 signatures are
collected by the end of the month to
month is at the end of September I see
well Tim we have until September 30 to
collect 200,000 signatures supporting
the wolf restoration initiative while
the official death
line four signature-gathering is
December 12th the self-imposed deadline
of September 30th was a requisite for
ensuring cost-effectiveness and building
essential momentum for the eventual
statewide campaign to pass the
initiative to 200,000 signatures would
be more than enough for the Secretary of
State for Colorado to say all right well
the Coloradans clearly want this to be
on the 2020 ballot these signatures more
than exceed the minimum threshold and
and therefore this Wolf's restoration
initiative will be on the 2020 ballot
and and then Coloradans will have a
chance to vote now folks all over the
country followers of yours in Texas
might say what Mike I don't get to vote
and I'd say well that's true but you can
still influence the future of your
national forests by choosing to support
the Rocky Mountain wolf project or the
Rocky Mountain wolf Action Fund it's
it's a really clear opportunity to
illustrate the power of direct democracy
the power of the people to rise up and
say we think this is an appropriate a
future for our great public lands in
western Colorado and and I want to also
just mention a few things related to
this number one I'll reiterate that the
the goal is six hundred thousand dollars
in additional funds to the Rocky
Mountain Wolf action fund wolf action
fund calm in bicep2 so 600 K by
September 15th in order to help gather
200,000 signatures from Colorado
residents by the end of September so
that's that's the goal and as you put it
just at the tail end of what you were
saying you know my interest in this is
is as a Texas resident as someone who is
interested in ecological restoration
which by the way we are all part of and
sustained by ultimately is is of
interest because of the last piece of
the puzzle characteristics which
find this which you've already talked
about in terms of the Continental
connection for a carnivore of this type
and so that that is reason enough to to
support this and you don't know this mic
but I'll tell you now what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna offer $100,000 matching
grant and what that means is if my
audience can provide a hundred grand
before September 15th and actually we
should make it even tighter than that
within a week of this podcast coming out
I will match that and provide another
hundred thousand dollars so you have
that commitment right off the bat yeah I
don't know what to say but yeah I had
never imagined that that but thank you I
can promise you this the money will be
put to very good use and you're standing
on high ground well I I appreciate that
and I'm not bullshitting people
listening uh Mike had had no idea I've
been doing a lot of additional reading
this has been something that's consumed
a lot of my time over the last few
months but especially in the last
handful of weeks and what I've bet on
startups in the past when I've made good
investments and I've had that sort of
gut feeling of importance there's very
rarely been a lot of doubt there have
been some shared characteristics oh
there's been an ambitious plan or a end
or a very achievable manageable
objective with gigantic long term
possible consequences if that makes
sense because you know saving the world
is not a good goal as stated as such but
in this case you have you have predators
introduced in small numbers 15 to 20
wolves per year very very manageable
very concrete which can then connect a
species continentally which can affect
ecosystems
nationally and and beyond nationally
that's that's really incredible
but that doesn't make it fully
actionable until you have a team on
board who can execute with a proven
track record of doing so and that's
where you Mike former manufacturing
engineering runs baseball player and
other people involved with this come in
so I really feel like this is a an
Archimedes lever we're a relatively
small amount of money can have an
enormous Li disproportionate output of
impact if that makes sense so suffice to
say I'll just reiterate if people listen
to his podcast donate at least 100k
within a week of this podcast coming out
Rocky Mountain Wolf action fund wolf
action fund calm I will match that with
100k of my own and what I also do and
I'll mention this again at the end is
I'll put together a short link on my
site so if you go to tim dot blog
forward slash wolf then it will take you
to a page that has links to all this
stuff so it'll be easy to find what what
can people do who don't have two
questions if people want to support in a
bigger way right so if they wanted to if
they want to give thousands or tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
dollars potentially I should they still
go to both Action Fund comm or is there
a better Avenue
well first Tim I gotta go back folks I
had really no idea I'm almost speechless
I didn't expect this and and as people
think I as I listen to Tim's very
generous offering challenge I was
reminded and I I'm an old field
biologist i don't want folks to think
otherwise but i have always been
enamored by poetry and and and i was
reminded of an important stretch of a
poem that if you don't mind
might it feels appropriate to me and
before I answer what could folks do
otherwise
wolf Action Fund calms a good place to
go but I want to share these lines
because you've so inspired me it's his
lines from Horatius at the bridge
Horatius was a Roman soldier who was
trying to predict Rome from an advancing
army this was a poem written in 1842 by
thomas babington macaulay it's a long
poem I'm not gonna read much of it I'm
actually not reading I've memorized
these lines but they they say simply
halt down the bridge sir council with
all the speed gee may I with two beside
me we'll hold the phone play in yon
straight path a thousand may well be
held by three now who will stand on
either hand and keep the bridge with me
Tim thank you brother anyway
Wolf faction fun.com is a powerful way
to get involved there's links there you
can talk to the people that run the
program I'm honored to be a member of
the science team for the Rocky Mountain
wolf project that's just Rocky Mountain
wolf project org and uh and those are
those are good ways to engage and if
folks want to really dive into the deep
end of the pool they will find willing
partner standing on shoulder to shoulder
to keep that bridge to make sure that we
stop the degradation of the planet and
use restoration as a great inspiration
to remind folks that we can choose we
can choose to live better with the world
this is the only world we're going to
get Tim here here and for people who
want to help but who don't have the
funds currently to donate and whether
they're Colorado residents or otherwise
how can they help with this it's
time-sensitive are there other ways for
people to help well for your Colorado
listeners certainly there there are ways
that you could volunteer as a Colorado
and to become a signature gather
yourself I understand
the website has instructions on how to
become a a petitioner what a great way
to engage in direct democracy I know as
an elected official that what we need in
this country is a more engaged
electorate signature-gathering is great
way to engage and if you can't volunteer
to gather signatures then of course you
can make doggone sure to sign the
petition so that you're saying to your
Secretary of State I want this on the
2020 ballot I want to I want to be able
to cast a vote for the future of the
gray wolf in the great public wild lands
of western Colorado and I will also just
answer a question that no doubt many
people have in their head because I did
which is can we do this digitally the
answer is no unfortunately there are
very strict rules for what can be
accepted in terms of signatures and
petitions and needs to be done in person
so what what I'll do is also work with
Mike and people running the wolf action
fund comm website to ensure that there
are instructions whether it's there or
on their social media at Rocky Mountain
Wolf spelled at ROC KY m TN wolf which
point people to where they can sign or
where they can volunteer for gathering
signatures because it is time-sensitive
so that's that's part of the reason for
for jumping on this and Mike if there
were if there were one or two books or
documentaries about wolves that really
influenced you or that you recommend
most to people do any come to mind yes
immediately one especially Tim is so
very important and it's not about wolves
specifically although there is an essay
in the book that speaks about wolves I
spoke about the essay earlier it's
entitled thinking like a mountain but
the book is a sand County Almanac
well how do you spell that the keys to
that one more time please a sand County
Almanac by a separate word sand sa ND
Almanac no sand okay County County
Almanac yeah a sand County Almanac by
Aldo Leopold is a fantastic book that
everyone should read it speaks to the
need for a land ethic it speaks to the
need for us to recognize were just as
much a part of this planet as the
wonders diversity of life that still
surrounds us that's what I would
recommend folks read a sand County
Almanac great and I'll link to that I
just found it
Oxford University Press the sand County
Almanac and sketches here and there
subtitle 1949 non-fiction book by
American ecologist forests or
environmentalist Aldo Leopold and he's a
great poet
it's a beautiful read you will not be
disappointed wonderful
well let's see Mike I think I think this
is a sensible closing spot I want people
while the iron's hot to consider if
they're so inclined helping with this I
don't take a whole lot of shots and I
pick very very very carefully I don't
take the spray-and-pray approach to
causes or engaging with feel-good
exercises I like to feel good don't get
me wrong but what I really like are
small targeted shots with small amounts
relatively small amounts of money that
can have gigantic impacts over not just
months but years decades and in this
case possibly centuries I mean it is
really a rare rare rare opportunity so
the the websites that people can check
out and I will put all of these under
tim dot blog forward slash wolf just to
make it easy to remember
but you can also visit the rocky
mountain wolf action fund that's the
most relevant for raising 600 K by
September 15th
that's 2019
which would then be used to help gather
200,000 signatures from Colorado
residents by the end of September the
other website Rocky Mountain wolf
project which is just Rocky Mountain
wolf project org and will add many
others the social as I mentioned earlier
on Twitter and elsewhere is at Rocky MTN
wolf and the the challenge grant stands
it is $100,000 from my pockets to this
cause if listeners can donate at least a
hundred thousand within a week of this
podcast going live so that is that and
Mike do you have any other closing words
recommendations thoughts you'd like to
impart to the audience before we close
this conversation well Tim pal let me
say again thank you so very much it's
been my high honor and I would say in
closing there's just no doubt that the
great public wild lands of western
Colorado need need to have their
wilderness soul restored in the form of
the gray wolf the lands need us the gray
wolf needs us Tim has sketched out a way
forward that everyone can contribute and
I'll leave the listeners with one final
thought Neil Wilson we spoke about Ed
earlier is a great man and a kind man
and a poet and one of my heroes and
Eadie wrote many years ago and maybe
this will inspire your listeners Tim to
rise up to your challenge and dr. Wilson
simply wrote there can be no purpose
more inspiriting than to begin the age
of restoration reweaving the wondrous
diversity of life that still surrounds
us I hope folks will help us do that to
him thank you pal
my pleasure and
this is this is this is very important
and it it did it did not start as an
emotional impulse for me it really began
as a sort of consideration of the facts
and how much could actually be done on a
continental scale with relatively so
little and it is a very small window of
opportunity with a clear deadline which
I like I actually enjoy those types of
table stakes but it does mean that need
to get moving
I should also say that I think in a lot
of ways the the the gray wolf is
supremely important also symbolically
and I think a lot about symbols and
metaphor because humans are are really
evolved to use story and metaphor and
symbol to piece together reality and
this isn't going to get too abstract
don't worry but for for I think a well I
don't think for centuries wolves were
gray wolves in this case the the canary
in the coal mined I mean really
foreshadowing some awful things that
have happened over time to ecosystems
certainly in the United States and
abroad and I think that it could really
be powerful for conversely the gray wolf
to become not the canary in the coal
mine but in this case a beacon of hope
and an example of strategy that actually
worked for reversing a lot of these
trends that are negatively dramatically
negatively impacting the world in which
we live so I it's it's it's a very clear
shot there's a clear strategy there's a
clear objective there's a good team
assembled it's very concrete
so I I really hope the people listening
well will join in I'll be right there on
the front line and on the bridge so to
speak yes on the bridge I'm right there
with you buddy on the bridge yes sir
so thanks thanks very much Mike for
taking the time truly my pleasure thank
you pal and for everybody listening as
always we'll have links to everything in
the show notes at tim dot blog forward
slash podcast and links for this episode
specifically at teamed up log ford slash
wolf thank you for listening hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend
so if you want to receive that check it
out just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's four hour work week com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
shipstation
if you've ever sold anything online or
if you sell anything online then you
know what a pain in the ass the shipping
process is it's time-consuming it's
expensive
you're always copying and pasting orders
from different sites trying to figure
out the best carrier so on and so forth
it's such a hassle and in the previous
life I shipped tens of thousands of unit
it's overseas domestically overnight
ground every possible carrier it drove
me bonkers shipstation
was created to make your life easier I
wish I had had it when I was in the biz
so to speak it has the most five-star
reviews of any shipping software four
point nine out of five for Magento users
four point eight out of five for Shopify
users four point five out of five for
big commerce users it goes on and on
whether you're selling on eBay Amazon
Shopify or more than 100 of their
popular selling channels shipstation
lets you access all of your orders from
one simple dashboard shipstation works
with all of the major shipping carriers
locally and globally including FedEx UPS
and the major local couriers like USPS
shipstation will recommend the best
carrier for your needs so that you know
that you're always getting the best deal
they even offer discounts on shipping
costs that are available to say you as a
one-person shop that would normally be
thought of as reserved for large fortune
500 companies so there are a lot of
benefits no other shipping platform
makes shipping faster easier and more
affordable and right now Tim Ferriss
your listeners get to try shipstation
free for sixty days when you use promo
code Tim it's risk free you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info just visit ship
station com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in Tim
T I am that ship station comm enter
promo code Tim check it out ship station
comm promo code Tim this episode is
brought to you by helix sleep last year
I focused on dramatically improving a
few things surprise surprise most
notably the quality of my sleep which
seems to affect just about everything
this led me to revisit you name it my
daily routine morning routine exercise
diet all the way to what I slept on and
I ended up getting all new beds here in
Austin Texas including mattresses from
helix sleep helix has built a sleep quiz
that takes two minutes to complete and
they use the answers to match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect
whether you're a side sleeper hot
sleeper cult super her you like plush
you like firm with helix there's no more
guessing of our confusion just go to
helix sleep calm Ford / Tim take their
two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life that is their
promise for couples helix can even split
the mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty and you can test drive
your mattress for 100 nights risk-free
right now helix is offering up to 125
dollars off of all mattress orders check
it out get up to 125 off at helix sleep
comm forward slash Tim that's helix
sleep comm forward slash Tim for 125
dollars off your mattress order tickly
helix sleep comm forward slash temp
you
[Applause]